let's go to someone let's go to yang
supporter from the nine one nine who's
yang supporter from the nine one nine
does that ring a bell uh yeah it rings a
bell for me and I have a very quick
question okay I just want to know what
did you think of the last season of Curb
Your Enthusiasm didn't see it
well I highly recommend it I've heard it
and I'd also like to really yeah and
also like I just looked right next to
Maya
right on my bedside table like right as
I was on hold but I have a book
recommendation for you which is the end
is always near by Dan Carlin it came out
in October and it like talks about
pandemics so a lot of people have been
giving it a second look but yeah it's
very good anyway
I hope you have a good day David hey but
before you go as a yang supporter what
are you doing in November I'm gonna be
holding my nose and voting for Joe okay
I know there's a big debate on the left
about that right now but I'm gonna be
voting for Jo I'm on your side
got it alright my friend thank you so
much appreciate the call all right thank
you alright so we've got so far today
Bernie guy is voting for Biden and yang
guy is voting for Biden very interesting